well I mean I'm a huge fan of imax I  mean I I think anything that enhances a  theatrical experience anything that  makes the movie you know something to  see in a cinema as opposed to waiting  for it to show up on your iPad is a good  thing and that's what we're facing it as  an industry now we have to provide their  incredible summer experience alpha if I  was seeing the movie in imax i would i  would absolutely suggesting it at 48  frames a second because it will give you  an immersive sense of reality like  taking the screen away and you're  looking into a window into the real  world and yeah 48 frames and imax is  probably the ultimate way to see this  film